welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee I'm councilor John
Hinton I am chairing the meeting today
my first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
additionally we will be using the
e-voting for this meeting on the modern
gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
to the possible use of those images and
sound recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the council
members of the public and press May
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the Press
are not lawfully excluded
can I move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
glad to see that you managed to
effort to make it counselor Brandon
to receive decorations of pecunery or
other registerable or non-registerable
interests by members
thank you chair I am actually a member
of the trustee Board of mid-suffolk
citizens advice thank you
so you're registering a non-pecuniary
council Osborne
um thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm an
observer for baber at the uh at the
citizens advice but I I don't have any
any interest in that at all
any others no
to receive notification of petitions oh
sorry
other registerable interest is that an
appointment that we make too
yeah
thank you
all right
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received yet
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 24th of October
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of those minutes
could I have a proposal in please
plenty
we'll start castling ladies first
councilor Grandin and the seconder
councilor Muller
the governance officer will conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
Council Osborne can I take your vote
full thank you
thank you chair that is 11 votes four
and one abstentions that is carried
24th of October have been confirmed
item five on the agenda questions by the
public
is by councilors
to item seven Jos stroke 22 23 review of
the local citizens advice and the cost
of living crisis
I'd like to invite the cabinet members
for communities to introduce the report
to the committee
councilman McLaren
thank
you
um
there's just one comment I would like to
make about this paper that we must give
credit to all the staff that have been
involved in producing this in a very
short period of time
and
a lot of hard work has gone into the
paper the other thing I would like to
highlight for members is that
communities heads it up that fact it's
the internal stakeholder group within
the council that has contributed to this
paper and so that covers all the other
directorates
and so I'm very happy to introduce Dar
Robinson as the Director of communities
and well-being to introduce the paper
thank you Chad
thank you Mary and for those I haven't
met before my name is di Robinson I'm
the interim director of communities and
wellbeing
um so what we're going to do today just
um I think someone's going to load my
slides up is that right perfect so we're
going to do a very brief introduction
and update on the five-point action plan
which we've been undertaking for the
last six months and but the majority of
the discussions today is also to
introduce our colleagues and their
citizens advice
um Colleen Sweeney and Simon
um to talk about their role in this and
how important the work they're doing is
and then we were hoping to then lead a
joint q a around both both parts of the
work together
that's what my clicker perfect so in
terms of a brief obviously you've
received the paper of the six months
update so that was to give you the
background and the context for today's
session
um so as a very brief highlight
um we have now appointed our cost of
living coordinator who came to join us
on the 3rd of October and that's Eliza
Dale who's with us today observing
um we have also been running
both internal and external cost of
living stakeholder groups and the idea
of that has been both as as Mary says to
work across the council to bring all the
different directives into that debate
and all the different contributions but
also to work with our external
stakeholders to pick up what else is
happening out in the wider community so
that we're informed of developments
there has been in this past year 30
uplift into the citizens advice in both
districts and which has been in addition
to the rolling three-year call Grant
um baber and mid-suffolk are actively
participating in the anti-poverty
subgroup set up by Suffolk County
Council there's a lot of work happening
at county level which incorporates all
the districts and it's been really
important that we've had that wider
stakeholder engagement with our partners
across the districts
um and we've had
the advantage therefore of central
um county-wide money being devolved into
districts to enable us to do some really
targeted work in our own districts which
has been a really helpful towards
delivering the plans and we've had a
number of referrals made and received
through the Suffolk warm Handover scheme
and the whole point of that is to
support our residents to be able to
access what they need across Partners
rather than only having one way in so we
can support people in that way and we've
also done a lot of work many of you will
have seen around
um with Suffolk County again to refresh
that Suffolk info link so all the
districts and areas have been trying to
connect up all the information residents
might need so that they can come in Via
any of our websites or in all different
approaches and get to the place that
they need to find out what they that the
actual support they need
and as I said you've had that um
six-month report
so just to let you know then so moving
forward
um one of the things we've really
learned from the past six months is how
quickly this situation develops there's
change happening all the time in terms
of emerging needs in terms of different
bits of government funding to manage and
think about how to distribute Etc
um so we really have recognized how
responsive the next six months plan
needs to be what we can't really do is
set something in stone and say we're
only going to do X because we have to
see what arises so we really want to be
able to respond in a timely manner so
therefore we're designing um the next
six months to be iterative and flexible
making sure that we can continue the
work in progress that has been working
and that we need to continue but also
recognize that working with our
voluntary Community sector Partners we
can respond to changes quickly and
efficiently and obviously the little
caveat in there saying you know
appreciating we don't have all the
answers clearly we don't have all the
answers what we're trying to do is work
with people in New and existing ways to
try and come up with the right responses
um we also recognize how important that
hyper local level work is with our
voluntary sector partners and that's
also around developing Community
resilience as well as trying to support
that immediate crisis
and I think in that we are learning and
using our learning from the covid-19
pandemic and what we saw happening then
in terms of future
priorities which seems to be said it's
excellent
um so there are several priorities we're
going to be looking at moving forward
what's important I think is initially
how we respond to the crisis because we
still have
a great number of people who are trying
to deal with the day-to-day in the short
term but we also need to be looking
forward as well to develop a sustainable
plan and enhance that Community
resilience so for example supporting
people through their immediate financial
crisis and supporting them with skills
to move forward and be able to sustain
that as they move forward in life
so we're looking at the crisis response
and in addition to what we already
looked at in the six months which you've
seen in the report
we're going to support our residents
through the winter by ensuring we're
mapping and supporting funding warm
spaces across the district and by those
warm spaces they're not just arbitrary
rooms with a heater heater on and it's
much more about enhancing the provision
that already exists and enabling the
voluntary sector to do maybe an extra
session a longer session that kind of
idea so really building into what
already exists
um and also we're trying to map out and
understand better the food bank
provision because that's been quite an
interesting we've got very formal
feedback but there's also a lot of
informal ones that we're trying to sort
of understand
um and we also want to make sure we're
developing kind of clear and tailored
Communications
um campaigns which are constantly using
different methodologies to reach people
with the right messages that they need
at the right time we can't always just
do a one a one-size-fits all around
those kind of campaigns we need to reach
out in different ways
and then we're also interested in
looking at that building Community
resilience as we move forward so trying
to where we can develop a preventative
approach to identify households at risk
before they get into that situation and
falling into crisis and obviously we
work very closely with our housing
colleagues and our customer colleagues
in doing that work
um within that addressing issues such as
digital exclusion and financial
capability which I referred to before
how we support people with that and
we're also developing um through the
UK's shared Prosperity fund we're hoping
to get the knowledge that we got the
money for that fairly soon to develop
Community supermarkets which is that
kind of bridge between the food bank
model and the core the commercial
Supermarket just trying to encourage
people back into a more sustainable way
of managing their food situation
um and also really importantly we need
to just kind of re-look at how we grow
the membership of our external
stakeholder meetings because actually
we're learning all the time there are
more and more people engaged in really
important work in in the districts that
we need to make sure where we're
bringing those people into our
conversations which includes those
Frontline workers who are working
closely with communities and households
and trying to get a little bit ahead
where we can and intervene where we can
see people at risk before they found
themselves in the worst situation
so in terms of citizens advice we're
very very pleased to have citizens
advice here
um they pay a really vital role in
everything that we've been doing we're
in a way a small part of what they're
doing as well in that sense
um and in terms of preventing and
relieving hardship throughout our
districts they've been really key in
terms of crucial advice and obviously
they'll talk much more to you about what
they've been doing
for us you know their insight into the
challenges being faced by residents has
been absolutely key and it's a critical
element of our systems approach
um to address this cost of living crisis
you know sharing those lenses that
people
are looking to has been really important
so now obviously I'd like to pass over
to Citizens advice who are going to
provide an update on their priorities
the key trends they've been seeing which
has been really useful and um so I'm
going to hand over to you I'm not sure
who's starting is that ukulele lovely
oh good morning everybody
um to introduce ourselves for those who
do not know us I'm Colleen Sweeney chief
officer at Sudbury and District citizens
advice and this is my colleague Simon
Clifton who is chief officer at citizens
advice mid-suffolk
um by way of reminder for those who were
present at our last joint scrutiny
presentation and to inform those who are
not I would like to speak briefly about
who we are and what we do
as you know we could all face problems
that seem complicated and intimidating
at citizens advice we believe no one
should have to face those problems alone
or without good quality independent
advice
we give people the knowledge and
confidence to find their way forward
whoever they are and whatever their
problem
so when we say whoever you are we do not
place any limits on the number of visits
the client makes we do not restrict to
any particular beneficiary group anyone
can come to see us for advice
we do not judge people who come to us
for help and when we say whatever your
problem
we give advice on an extensive range of
areas and we work with Partners whenever
people need further specific support on
the more specialist in pop that we do
not have
what we mean by Find A Way Forward
we do not make decisions for clients we
present options and Empower them to act
or assist further when the client is
considered to have need for more
in-depth support
we match the support we give to the
clients needs
so we do have clients who just need us
to point them in the right direction and
we have other clients who need more
support so it's a case of assessing how
confident each person is and the right
approach for them
foreign
crisis in decades
citizens advice to see more people
coming to us for help with Crisis
Support energy problems and not have
enough money to make ends meet than ever
before
his prices rise people make more and
more difficult decisions about what they
want to cut back on and need to rely on
community support because they don't
have enough to live on
that Community Support includes food
banks Community shops and financial aid
from local charities
the rise in food and energy costs could
not have come at a worse time
these are essential products that take
up a larger proportion of the budget in
low-income households and other income
groups
the poorest households are spending a
higher proportion of their income on
food than higher income households this
is also true for energy use as they tend
to live in older less efficient houses
that require more Heating and are more
likely to be on prepayment meters with
higher energy tariffs
lower income the low-income groups are
also the ones with the least number of
financial options available to help
absorb those price Rises
higher income health councils can use
Savings credit cards not saying we'd ask
them to do but they would do as a buffer
to increase prices of essential Goods
the government defines lower income
household as a household that lives on
less than 60 percent of UK average
disposable income
so a couple with no children with an
annual income of up to one seventeen
thousand one hundred pound before
housing costs would be a low income
household
but citizens advice and our partners are
supporting households whose incomes are
above this threshold
as partners in the delivery of the local
welfare assistance scheme we lobbied
Suffolk County Council to increase the
qualifying income for financial support
from 17 100 pounds to twenty five
thousand
at citizens advice we regularly assess
charitable support for family with two
wave journals and incomes of fifty
thousand
the cost of living increases are
impacting on all of these are sorry on
all the cost of living increases are
impacting on all and there are
households where they were just managing
but increases in rent mortgage payment
and other interest payments now mean
that they cannot afford to manage their
debts
this is only going to increase as the
full impact of interest rate Rises and
inflation filters down to the housing
market
rents will rise mortgages will be
unaffordable
rent and mortgage arrears will climb and
landlords will withdraw from the rental
market
the risk of households being made
homeless is its highest since 2008.
oh
foreign
of our clients have a disability or a
long-term health condition
are female
those on prepayment meters there is no
list of how many residents are on
prepayment leaders across our districts
the numbers needing help with fuel
vouchers for prepayments continues to
increase and will do so through the
winter months despite government
financial assistance
long gas grid consumers
60.1 of mid-suffolk residents have no
access to Mains gas
this is the same percentage as Cornwall
oil is the predominant heating fuel when
gas is not available across the both
districts and the cost of oil has
increased considerably over the past 12
months
many residents cannot afford to pay The
Upfront costs of all deliveries this
means tanks remain dry and people who
are cold or revert to other means
heating such as portable gas
and Suffolk Farm Rescue already
highlighted the dangers of these devices
now becoming more widespread
we've also identified that single people
under 25 years old particularly male
appear to be disproportionately impacted
with lower wages and benefits than the
over 25s
they're across both districts our client
demographic is now far greater for those
who are economically active than those
who are retired despite both districts
having an aging population
that could suggest that the cost of
living crisis has not impacted on those
who are retired as much as those who are
still working as greater government
support has been given to those over 66
years of age
however
using our data alone is not conclusive
and Community intelligence will be key
to building a better understanding of
the need across all age groups and areas
this chart shows the trend for some of
our key costs of living issues based on
the number of clients we help each month
so red is the personal Independence
payment
green is energy
purple is energy debt
blue is charitable support and food
banks
yellow is council tax careers
the graph demonstrates the combined
increase in clients across both
districts
for these five key cost of living issues
[Applause]
this graph shows you the comparison of
the number of clients we've helped with
Crisis Support for the last four years
so the the two important colors there
are the yellow and the blue
the includes referrals to food banks
other charitable financial support and
to enable people to make ends meet
localized social welfare it shows the
actual on a trend line for the year the
yellow line was last year the blue line
is this year the dotted blue line was
was our
um
trajectory but we are above that
so as you can see we have supported more
people with Crisis Support each year
we're above the trend live across sport
this year and that undoubtedly has
contributed to the huge increase in
demand that we've been experiencing
providing Crisis Support to the
residents of mid-suffolk and favor is
unlikely to decrease and we fear it's
likely to increase further
so this graph is a breakdown of the
types of charitable support that we have
helped our clients to access
the blue column is food banks
the yellow column is charitable support
and the red column Is wealth local
welfare assistance
if you just looked at Food Bank issues
it would appear that they were just
about the same
but actually when you put all the data
together you can see that local welfare
assistance is giving people a lot of
that short-term assistance
from mid-2020 to September 22 Local
welfare assistance included Fuel and
Supermarket vouchers and additionally
the provision of household white goods
in October 22 Local welfare assistants
moved to a cash payment only
the local welfare assistance scheme is
majority funded by central government
funding through the household support
fund
the current run of funding is due to end
in March 23.
and if this were not to continue we can
expect that Demand on food banks will
increase after this date
for the past three years the energy
price cap has been around
1 130 pounds per year for a household on
average use
in September 2022 the price jumped by 54
to 1971.
as you'll be aware the company
introduced the energy price guarantee
and an energy bill support scheme
together these measures will reduce the
average bill to April of this year April
of next year to 2 100 pounds
the graph here is out of date because uh
We've not amended it since the Autumn
statement
so the next figure for a quarter
to 2023 is probably going to be 3 000
pounds so without the ngi price cap the
expected case would be 3702 pounds now
we take those figures from the um
Cornwall insights organization which has
been quite accurate up to now
this table shows the unique client
numbers and client issues for both local
citizens advice offices
in 2021-22
April 22 to October 22. and projected
four-year figures for 22 to 23.
the unique clients are someone who we
saw at least once during this year
but could have been seen on more than
one occasion
so if we help someone in April and then
again in August on a different issue
then they will only be counted once as a
unique client
so now we move on to our client
number 22.
and then again projected for four year
figures for this financial year
as you can see large device area is for
benefits and tax credits followed by
debt and financial capability
but the actual percentages if you look
across this table are pretty are pretty
similar to the previous years but what
is not similar is the number of clients
which is increased dramatically
foreign
benefits and tax credits
although the percentage of issues show a
small increase of three percent on last
year it is projected that we have helped
clients with 2
529 more benefit issues than the
previous year
the largest increase in benefits has
been for personal Independence payments
and attendance allowance renewals and
applications
we are now the primary advice service
for welfare benefits no statutory
organization has a responsibility to
support people to navigate the welfare
benefits system
the number of issues have increased due
to the complexity of the issues that
people are presenting with
[Applause]
the next table highlights debt so
although the percentage issues now shows
a one percent drop on last year is
projected that we will have helped an
additional
1264 clients with debt issues than the
previous year
is now the case that most of the clients
have come to us with a debt issue
present with a deficit budget make an
intervention incredibly difficult
because we don't really have many
solutions for people in those
circumstances
with the increase in interest rates well
the cost of living factors many more
people who have been able to manage
their debts will no longer be able to do
so going forward
demand for our debt service is not going
to reduce and we expect we're going to
get new client groups who now move into
the uh that are able to unable to manage
their own debt group
utilities including energy and
Communications
the percentage increase for energy
issues from last year to this is four
percent
however in terms of client issues this
year they have doubled over the last
year's already high figures
more people are now in fuel poverty and
this will only increase as Energy prices
rise further
thank you
so moving to food banks and charitable
support these are combined these are the
combined figures of both districts
look at these in isolation you could
think that the increase is not as large
as you would have thought in a cost of
living crisis the percentage of issues
remains broadly similar and the increase
is projected to be 725 issues over the
last year
in mid-suffolk we refer more people to
food banks and submarine districts but
something district has supported more
clients through local welfare assistance
provided Supermarket vouchers so have
made fewer fewer referrals to food banks
our system that we use in citizens
advice would cause local welfare support
on a different funder code which is why
it's not included here so the earlier
graph which showed The Crisis Support
the lines going up it's probably more
representative of the current situation
so on the next slide I hope is going to
play
did we do it work before Malaysia for
you when you tried it or not
so yeah we'll um we'll go to the next
slide go to the next slide so this next
slide is
um what we think our client thinks you
should hear
so mid-suffolk we've been doing quite a
lot of work with lived experience groups
so that's groups of clients that we've
helped before who tell us what what they
got from us and what they'd like to see
in the future so I'm hoping I hope this
will play
give it a go
why did I first come to Citizens advice
it was the means that I had
of getting my problems sorted out you
know
that this is the biggest problem I had
and I was despondent I didn't know what
I didn't know what to do I didn't know
where to turn you know and I was getting
it if that wasn't for my little dog
I think I would have um
not thought commit suicide but uh I just
think I would just light it over and let
the world go by I'd be well
the summons the court and all that sort
of thing from non-payment of money I
mean Leo has been an absolute godsend to
me you know she's helped me out no end
getting all my problems sorted out along
with um Steve
he's he's helped me out as well for
benefit wise and all that sort of thing
you know yeah he done for him got me
some benefits you know which I didn't
know I was entitled to because I've
never been on benefits before in my
whole life
I appreciate immensely what they've done
and their knowledge
of their jobs
citizens advice they
they
contacted all the people that owe you
money to and and help me along that them
sort of lines and
yeah we've had all my budget planned you
know and what I can afford what I can't
afford what I can do it's just been
amazing you know because I'm not
obviously I'm a
a country boy who doesn't sort of have
money
and I've been sort of guide us through
this different stages of trying to you
know what you can do with your money and
not just hit up against the wall for
whatever better word
the wife left me and I didn't know what
to do I mean I've got no household
budgets or anything like that and I just
let everything slip and she didn't help
me actually because she left a lot of
debt in the house which I knew nothing
about but now I've been putting a
picture on a trained me really on what
to do and what not to do and I'm well
I'm just happy again now you know it
made me more secure in my life you know
and it just it just changed my whole
outlook
well they need to understand the people
who fund the citizens advice what they
are actually doing for the community and
how they're helping people get on with
their lives and sort things out
that's the way I look at it anyway
that's what I see and that's what
they've done for me
and but as I say between us ourselves
the citizens advice they have they've
saw me have put me on the right Road
well the type of service that I need to
face the challenges ahead
are coming from citizen advice because
their knowledge is is second to none I
mean they've got people in there
who know what they're talking about you
know they can guide you through all the
different stages
the friendliness and the approachability
of the the citizens advice
is the best thing you know you they're
approachable you just come and see them
and they're humans like we are and
they'll come and help you
I would say somebody like me I don't
like computers I absolutely detest the
things and you need you don't want a
robot sitting there going like that you
need interaction with with proper people
you know that's what I would tell them
you know it's the way well we're going
backwards you say that because everybody
now wants digital things and everything
else
but the way with me I like face-to-face
contact with people so I can see a
proper person
knows to say if it wasn't through word
of mouth I wouldn't have known about
citizen advice you know and I'm glad I
did
I'm glad I do now anyway
and so I'd just like to say a big a big
thank you to Leah who's helped me out
and Steve who who they've both been
worth their weight in gold
you know and it's people who know
they can guide you you know that's the
best thing
you know and it's not a bad world out
there you know that's what I've come to
you know to look at
so that was the that was the actual
voice of the client
um and we've got several of those um
videos of different plants but they're
quite long so one today but those are
attending my AGM will see some more on
on Thursday but uh yeah I think that's
quite an impactive um video really
so Colleen
why did I first come for Citizens advice
thanks Harry that'll do
[Laughter]
Okay so
more importantly than anything else in
our organization are our volunteers and
the wonderful work we do uh what they do
our organizations rely very heavily on
our volunteer Workforce to help us to
deliver our quality services to our
communities the chart shows that the
situation with volunteers is not the
same for both districts
in Sudbury we've been successful in
recruiting new volunteers and have been
able to go some way to recover from the
losses we saw around March 21.
in mid-suffolk the recruitment of
volunteers has been more of an issue and
at best the new recruits are only
replacing those who have left
volunteers play a crucial role in both
organizations
although in Sudbury we had we have had
success recently the volunteer landscape
remains incredibly competitive across
the county and country with most
Charities reporting issues with
volunteer recruitment
the demand of our services is evident
from the data that we've shared within
our presentation to you
started to build again from October last
year and at the moment shows no sign of
declining
cost of living issues are now the
majority of the client's concerns and
the complexity of their issues have
never been seen before
we're going to tackle this in
partnership with other organizations
including yourselves and I'm pleased to
be seen as a major partner within the
district's cost of living action plans
we welcome the opportunity to discuss
and debate what we're seeing in the
communities and work in an integrated
way with you and others
but as we know there is more to do on
this and we will remain engaged in the
process
so along with the increased demand in
common with everyone else we are not
immune to increased organizational costs
our fixed costs are not that fixed now
with rises in Energy prices in
particular about our largest cost will
always remain salaries
although we have small numbers of paid
staff these costs are now becoming very
significant
we do not have the option of just paying
more to retain staff and it's fair to
say that we are fortunate our team treat
their employment as a vocation as we
cannot afford to pay them what others do
for similar roles
we're very concerned about the situation
around Call funding
core funding is what it says it is and
provides funding for your core service
in both our cases we do not receive
sufficient Call funding to deliver a
generalist advice service
both districts are the most supportive
of funders to us and your 30 uplift
drive this year was very much
appreciated
you're further showing your support by
entering into a rolling three-year
funding agreement
our forces is not the case elsewhere
and a common response at the moment from
other fund has been we don't provide
funding for core services
so our question if you don't have a cool
service what sort of service do you
provide
after yourselves the next largest amount
of unrestricted funding for core funding
we receive is from what was the ccg and
now the ICS and Suffolk County Council
all I can report at the time of this
presentation is that we've received no
notification of an intention to continue
to provide us with any funding post
March 2023
involved from the start in the
production of the district council's
five-point action plans
we are proud to be considered a key
partner in moving to a more integrated
system
we look forward to seeing the action
plan refresh to see what other
organizations can be brought into this
process to better support the residents
in the districts
we know that our experience in
supporting people in hardship is
valuable we are Keen to work in any
partnership that provides the best
support possible to our
communities
the demographic and Geographic factors
of our districts impacts on how we all
react to emerging situations
when we talk about levels of deprivation
there are districts across the country
who have higher levels than either
mid-suffer called baber but at citizens
advice we see deprivation every day
going forward we anticipate more people
being in in work poverty We believe We
will see what was the minority group of
households in hardship in our districts
grow to become the majority
with the cost of living impacting on
more people there will be increases in
levels of deprivation and there is a
need to scale up resources to meet that
need in both organizations
there are occasions when we feel that
the sharing of intelligence between all
interested parties could be better
we are hoping that as we move to a more
integrated system of work that this will
help us to better understand the current
situations across all communities
this intelligence is gathered by all
office and officers and members so we
need to put systems in place to collect
and analyze that data
the five-point action plan is to start
and we know each Council understands
just how important it is to help people
with the cost of living crisis
we work across many advice areas and
although progress has been made we often
see occasions where the council could
have more Integrated Systems of work
internally within and between
departments
and we understand that that's that's
something that you're talking about Dave
so it fits into fits into Travis plans
an example of this is that whilst
working with a client on cost of living
issues they stated that they had just
received a grant from environmental
health to replace the boiler in the home
that they owned
it transpired that the client had
received a renovation grant which is
awarded where they are assessed as
living in a property in a serious state
of disrepair and a hazard to the
household
we received no referral from
environmental health but the client
presented to us with clear cost of
living issues
whilst the actions of environmental
health had addressed an immediate need
for that client there were no evidence
that any other wider determinants and
needs of the individual were considered
a very successful strategy employed by
other councils including Swansea is
within their poverty strategies
every department and individual has an
objective to support residents with the
cost of living crisis
were that to be brought in here then
this would focus minds and allow the
sharing of intelligence to better
support the client Journey
imagine what we could achieve if we set
up multi-disciplinary teams we're all
worked as one to achieve joint
objectives
we'll get in there I promise you we are
so future challenges
so at the top there we put funding so
funding is often short-term to us it
makes it very difficult for us to plan
in a strategic way we've done
Diversified our funding streams as much
as we can and take on new short-term
projects for bespoke services to
specific client groups and that goes
some way to supporting our other core
costs but Project funding does not
replace the need for core funding
so without sufficient core funds we're
at risk of losing experienced specialist
case workers when the project funds come
to an end
we know that the amount of debt and
benefit advice will continue to grow and
we must do all we can to retain that
part of our service offer
we are very grateful as we said earlier
for the 30 uplift but we do need to ask
that consideration is made to the fact
that the increased running costs need
for growth to meet demand is not
something that will reduce in future
years
the additional funds this year have
allowed us to increase capacity in
response to the cost of living crisis
which we all know is not going away in
you at any time soon
accessibility we are passionate about
being based within our community and
providing a local service to the
residents within both districts
we work hard to ensure that we're
accessible to all clients but as we know
this can be challenging within
particular our rural communities
can we do more yes can we do it by
ourselves no
that really goes back to the previous
slide and delivering more integrated
services for you and other organizations
so we kept this slide in from last year
just to show that the it does show an
integrated system of work
which we contribute to for our work
within the community and we just like to
finish by saying both of us that we're
we're very proud to be partners with
both District councils and we hope that
partnership can grow and continue
thank you
take me away my funder then I was just
going to say any questions
thank you I've got loads of questions
but the one that I really need to ask
first I think is you've had the 30
uplift
were there any strings attached to that
what could you spend that on and Ally to
that
when you talked about the numbers of
volunteers and staff
um you talked about strict numbers of
volunteers are you seeing that with
fewer volunteers of the volunteers
having to put in more hours are the
number of volunteer hours
going down in line with the number of
volunteers star well along with a number
of volunteers thank you
with the 30 uplift we are being asked to
show in monitoring reports what we've
done in addition to what we normally do
to to use that extra funding when in
fact it's it's in a nutshell
we've had we're having to grow to meet
demand constantly and even before the
crisis got to its desperate point at the
moment we were finding that our costs
were Rising so it's it's really just
being eaten up to meet demand and help
to cover increased costs in Sudbury I
don't know if that's the same in Stone
Market with regards to voluntary hours
we've recently um our Treasurer recently
wanted to do a bit of work on not only
the volunteers but the staff hours that
are increasing because we're all working
extra hours to meet demand and she feels
that that's not shown a true reflection
of our costs
Simon may want to add to that it's a
very mid-suffolk point of view the 30
uplift
um contributed directly to our core
costs
us being able to meet I'll call call
costs and us being able to meet the
extra demand that we've seen
which was the purpose of that Grant
volunteer numbers we have on we have
about the same number of volunteer
advisors who are working more hours
so um yeah the we we do a a calculation
at the end of each year which tells us
what our volunteer hours would equate to
in financial terms and again for
Mid-South a couple I haven't got the
accounts in front of me but I think
again we're about 30 up so we're around
about 250 000 pound Mark again as to
what their contribution would cost us if
we had to pay someone to do that wrong
does that answer your questions
counselor
Joe I just add one thing so you say that
30 to largely for both of you has gone
on
um to me demand core costs and so on is
that salary or is that because your
energy bill has gone up or
or you know what what or is it actually
we would say an increasing costs anyway
because the cost of living is going up
so of course like anybody else our costs
are increasing but we've actually to
meet demand we've actually had to put
another employed role in in between
supervisors and advisors to support the
supervisors whose days becoming
overwhelming
staff
to meet to meet demand similarly
can I have one other Last Promise last
question what does 30 look like I mean I
in in numbers terms in pounds pound
pound Shillings and Pence what does 30
look like for mids I think it was 30 000
pounds
which then meant so in in um income
terms mid-suffolk District Council were
by far our largest funder last year as
they have been for the last few years so
that brought us up to nearly 40 percent
of our total income came from
mid-suffolk district council with a 30
000 pound extra
um
died did you want to come in on that no
okay Council I've been young you had a
question thank you Mr chairman um I'm
just concerned at the decline in the
number of volunteers
um so what is the cause of that
um because clearly with your volunteers
and I suspect that
your staff and the volunteers could be
suffering from overload of some sort
um and and what do you think could be
done to encourage new volunteers because
clearly you know that's an important
issue for you
I think um what we described in our
presentation we're not we are not
everybody is experiencing issues in
recruiting volunteers some of the things
that we are hearing now is there are
more people having to remain in work
because of their own cost of living
issues so there's more people there's
less people retiring on finals a lot of
our volunteers come to us because they
they finished on a final salary pension
scheme those really don't sort of exist
too much now but a new one on us is
Grandparents being required to provide
additional child care
to allow their children to do more hours
at work
so that it's it's a combination it
it's a real concern to us because we are
volunteer-led organizations
and we're doing all we can I haven't I
mean you know you and Harry I didn't
want to bring in another we've got
another video which we've done with jump
uh councilor Muller is one of our
trustees and saying which is we've we've
done a video trying to recruit
volunteers using volunteers you know we
so we try and publicize it but it's a
real concern you've only got to look at
a number of Charity shops that don't
seem to be opening all days
so it's across it is across the board
um that's the concern that we are
Colleen
nothing we need to add to Simon's
explanation no to the
that we really think are impacting on
people going out and volunteering so
maybe covid had something to do with it
and people got used to being at home and
and not going out and about so much so
that's the only thing we can really we
can really suggest isn't it
I would say on burnout I think that's a
really good point
um because in our case the majority of
volunteers that asked were the ones that
were in covert as well
so you know we are really conscious
about burnout
um so we there's um so I've got Mental
Health First Aid has trained to
recognize
um you know anything that's happening
between the volunteers uh
another issue is that our client base is
becoming more demanding
I think that's society Society seems to
have bred a more demanding demographic
at the moment
and that can prove quite challenging
and some of the stories that the the
tales that we're hearing are they can
impact on an individual with that person
trying to help
so we do all we can on that
um but no anything that the members can
do to assist us with volunteering and
recruiting of volunteers would be very
much appreciated
that's the scarf
well I mean we've heard from
officers and the citizens advice this
morning about the way that we're trying
to integrate the cost of living crisis
and make make it so that officers are
constantly thinking about it and there
appears to be some further work that we
can obviously do to that so I think
but one of the ways I think that um we
might be able to help more
um it seems to me that citizens advice
is very heavily reliant on volunteers
and
the very staff
would it be an idea if citizens advice
perhaps had staff that worked jointly
for the district and and for Citizens
advice like a true integrated system so
that you had an officer in place at
could be your first point of contact
into the district because it seems to me
we need a little bit better integration
so I'm just wondering what the citizens
advice view on that type of concept I
mean I mean whoever pays for it you know
put that to one side but the concept of
someone working with you
we're fully in favor of any
multi-disciplinary approach to tackle
this
and
we are restricted by our income
so when I turned around long and say die
what a more disciplinary approach here
right guys can say right what are you
gonna give me I'm going to say uh right
so because if I then have to if I then
say I'm going to commit something to
that multi-disciplinary approach and the
team what do I stop doing that I'm doing
now
so we have to integrate better we know
that you know we're not the best at it
right the council's not the best at it
but we've got to do it because if we
don't we're not going to tackle what
we're seeing
you know so we got to stop the
duplication we've got to make the
customer straight in all words client
Journey as seamless as possible so that
when they contact either of us or other
partners that come into the cost of
living plan right they know they're
going to talk the most appropriate
resource and they're going to move
through seamlessly in the most efficient
manner and get them the best result but
we have to understand that we might not
get the result that they want at the end
because we've got a very demanding
demographic but we have to do that we
can't keep working in silos and
isolation we're doing a hell of a lot
more than we were this time last year
right so we are better than we were last
year but we can be better so we would
sign up to multi-disciplinary approach
but we cannot commit funds to do that
yeah and Simon do you get after you've
got very good support from from this
Suffolk and Bay the councils what sort
of support are you getting from
departmental work and pensions
if any
um so the DWP the the the support of DWP
has provided during the um covert and
the cost of living has primarily been
that they have been the front facing
part of the household support fund
so that the money that the County
Council takes actually comes from the
Department of work and pensions
um
Colleen said in our presentation
the the glaring the glaring missing part
at the moment no stash Street
organization has responsibility to help
anybody navigate the welfare benefit
system
yeah and that is damning
you know so the dwp's role at the moment
from what we're seeing is job centers
and work coaches getting people back
into work and um supporting people to
work more if they're claiming Universal
Credit
but the other the the huge increases we
have seen in personal Independence
paying claims and attendance allows
claims it is absolutely huge I haven't
got to slide for you but there's a slide
at our AGM in Mid-South it was on
Thursday for those that are coming but
it is absolutely huge and that's because
people are being told you need to claim
this now in mid-suffolk I so persons
against payments a lot of people try and
do the first bit themselves they ring up
they get a form they fill out the form
they submit it they then refused they
then come to us with something it's
called a mandatory reconsideration
so I can tell you that 80 of people that
we see who applied on their own
the person then independence payment are
unsuccessful
they then come to us and eighty percent
of the people we help are successful at
mandatory reconsideration so that tells
you that they are entitled but it's just
how you make that application
so I don't even answer you you know the
DWP is primarily Now set up to support
people to return to work
yeah Council Carson
thank you very much and thank you for
the presentation it was absolutely
fantastic as always
um
it seems to me looking at this and and
reading the um paper
um a lot of this is unclaimed benefit
unclaimed pension credits and um that
kind of um that kind of thing so the the
help is there it's actually getting the
help to the people before
it's some too late and they've run into
I'm dead
if um
have you ever tried
um action days
um where you invite people to come in
and talk
um I don't know I I don't know exactly
how it would work but I believe that um
it's something that can be done with the
local authority to um get people in
talking about things
um before situations get too serious
something that we're very keen on at the
moment and we know that's much needed is
what we call Financial budgeting advice
Financial capability or budgeting advice
and that's always a useful way to spot
where we can assist someone in
increasing their income and reducing
their outgoings to better manage what
they have left we're seeing more and
more people with less disposable income
than they need to meet basic bills or
just in they just don't have enough
coming in to for what needs to go out
without any disposable income so it's
difficult to manage a budgeting session
with somebody in that position or
somebody who's in debt
we also
um
do it carry out a benefits check for
every client that comes through the door
unless it's obviously inappropriate so
seeing a client for something that might
be a neighbor dispute wouldn't stop us
from looking at offering a benefits
check to make sure that they're claiming
their pension credit or if they've
disabilities or long-term health
problems that they're in the seat of
some form of disability payment
so we do what we can to ensure that
people we see are in gaining everything
they're entitled to
and we also do carry out a lot of
awareness stands I'm sure and Simon's
office do a lot of publicity and
awareness too in various places where we
have themes where we're advising people
just you know in a in a market stall
situation or Supermarket or a local
community center and our advisors that
go out to those are always talking to
people and showing giving that awareness
about what we might need to be claiming
um does that answer your question
yeah I think that last thing that you
were talking about Simon Doom was
exactly what I was thinking it sounds
like you're already doing that you're
going out into the both offices do a lot
of Promotional and awareness work
wherever it's appropriate yeah and
um the yeah the question on to that
would be can the local authorities help
you with that in any way I think that um
it's been raised I think it's a very
good idea that we have action days and
I'm sure it will go in the refresh only
die
so I think it's I think it is but we are
not the only organization working with
people and that's the most important bit
going forward is we need to identify
more organizations that are providing
this support you know we we are the
groups that are the citizens advice are
the ones that provide the primary the
highest numbers that have helped to
clients but there are lots of other
smaller groups could bring an awful lot
of knowledge and intelligence to to it
but uh yeah action day is a good idea
sorry I missed your point there
I think I missed your point sorry
Council Carter
thank you
um just wanted to start by see you've
mentioned before about being grateful to
it and I want to add my own personal
gratitude to you I was a former client
you sorted out my housing benefits my
disability benefits my wife's carers
benefit everything if it wasn't for help
but yourselves provided me with I may
not be here today because I was in the
real low place I was homeless at the
time but so my gratitude
um and I'm glad to hear but you you feel
included with the process of integrating
this
in a way you're being heard but I know
is there more that you feel that we
should be doing to help not just as a
council but as counselors should we be
listening more should we be doing more
and also this is a public forum a local
government organization
are there bodies out there which
you feel you should be receiving more
help from if they're not giving you a
help why aren't they in your opinion and
what more should you be it what should
be done what not more isn't it being
needed to tackle this crisis this is a
we all would like to know what more do
you feel needs to be done and how they
should start doing it
foreign
thank you because it's always nice to
hear somebody that's had a personal
experience over us you know and uh you
know there'll be times we get it right
at times we get it wrong we've got it
right get yourself so thank you for that
so
what more can the council do well really
primarily I think that every
colleague mentioned it but Community
intelligence is absolutely key to this
right so as members you're in the
community
you've got people coming to you and
saying they've got these issues right we
need a process that you can report that
in
what you are seeing all right what is
happening a prime example for us is the
number of pop-up food
shops food banks they're everywhere
right and we need to coordinate it
because at the moment it is just an
uncoordinated piece of work that needs
to be done
but
those are the sort of things that we
need
Council to do so when we speak about
everybody in the council having an
objective within their appraisal process
to support the residents of both
districts with cost of living
it's a thing and we're not knocking
environmental health because actually
they help this person massively by
replacing the boiler
but what we're saying is but did you
really just go in do the boiler and then
walk away
because there must be that person
couldn't afford a boiler and and their
criteria for for actually getting the
ground was such that it was in such a
state of disrepair and a hazard to the
family what else happened so we're not
we're not knocking environment we're
just saying that whole
mindset within the council if we had
that mindset in the council across all
areas offers us members then the amount
of community intelligence we gain be
huge and from when we gain that
Community intelligence then we know best
how to how to support
you know because at the moment you're
getting our side of what we're seeing
but others aren't haven't got their
voice but in the refresh I'm sure more
groups will be brought on so and the
other one you talk about what other bug
bodies
well
all I'd say on that is
bear in mind this live streamed is that
I would say
that we need to stop duplication
and we need to fully integrate services
so any organization whether that be
voluntary or statutory that has an
impact and improves cost of living
crisis for one person even say one
person has to integrate services with
everybody else
and that's about what I already saw
um just to add to that on the second
point it it really is what we're looking
for is is
um promoting an awareness amongst
officers and and members to just have
that that awareness that you know
a person could benefit from other
services and that that starts to move
forward
Council Grandin
thank you chair
um I think I saw in one of your earlier
slides
um that under 34s was a category that
has been coming to you for a lot of help
um that might be a surprise to some of
us
um can you tell me a bit about that the
profile of that kind of person and also
how you can help them or how you do help
them
so under 25s
um so the national minimum wage
increases
at 23 I think it is so we see that
people are receiving less money
younger
we see a lot of care leavers
care leavers is a real concern
Who coming to the workplace lacking
skills
the better welfare benefit system does
not really support people as well as
somebody over 25
.
um
and we see more people in debt under 25.
so our
since covid our client demographic has
changed quite dramatically so
pre-covered our client demographic was
primarily 60 plus
which you'd expect because we've got an
Asian population
what covid did it introduced to us a new
client demographic of those in in
economically active so they were in work
but being in work and couldn't cope
so we raise it because under 25 single
men
seem to be more disproportionately
affected
right and we can't say why definitively
but we need to look at it don't we all
of us need to look at it and decide why
that is there's going to be a reason
there won't be one
um and that's why we need to integrate
Services because somebody from Health
could bring something in and say that
this is that and you know it's
it's really about sharing what we know
that's what it is but I can't really
give you a definitive answer sorry on
why only the care leavers don't get as
much in benefits and don't get aren't
able to earn as much under the minimum
wage
we have seen a significant increase in
debt yeah
in that age group
how how would so that there isn't so
much um available to them centrally how
do you go about trying to assist those
people
well we would again we'd look at
maximizing income budgeting skills and
managing debt
in the usual way through casework
specialist case work
so when somebody comes to us what we do
what we try to do is maximize our income
so we try to maximize your income and
reduce their expenditure
so it's about budgeting a lot of the
under 25s come to us with poor financial
capability skills
can't budget
there's a lot of work being done trying
to be done through schools now
the County Council within the
collaborative communities board I was a
meeting on Friday and one of the schemes
there was and I think particularly out
here it was to provide funding for
organizations to go into schools to give
Financial capability advice
these are longer term aims these are
longer term aims but
we do see a lot of people who have
poor
living skills
thank you and um do you also sorry sorry
may I ask one more okay supplementary
thank you um where appropriate as there
are said to be quite a lot of jobs for
younger people where appropriate to also
try and find them a job or push them
into
helping them to find a girl that that
isn't our role okay
um but we would hope that when we've we
do know through various um surveys that
we carry out that when we have supported
somebody and we've assisted them in
getting on track financially in with
regards to their debt that they're
mentally in a better place to go out and
and move forward
and one of the things we would say if
someone's trying to maximize they think
their income is that you should be
considering a job yeah and so and to be
fair we're seeing more and more people
who are in work
so that might not even be an appropriate
thing to mention to them really
and CNN Council up in your I think we've
started to get a lot of
covering the same ground again there so
I think think carefully of your
questions please
so I'd um
three little ones and then perhaps a
bigger one but
um and it's actually for probably more
for our officers because in your
presentation you
mentioned um
the Suffolk warm Handover and I don't
know what that that is so if you explain
a bit about that and also Community
supermarkets
uh what what is that exactly
um
and then
I guess the one for the
well for for either of the office or the
CIBC the um
the voucher scheme whether that's
working for people with well with for
people with um
to buy oil for heating oil
put in a tank
and then the the
other one is we've
talked about
the message or it seems we're getting is
integration is required
um we now have a
cost of living
Tsar if you like or a coordinator
which strikes me that might be the
getting coordination
a
citizens advice and and the council
would that would be a
a good starting place and can you
comment on that
um do you get referrals at the moment
from
from baber or mid-suffolk
should I start from the top
so Suffolk information partnership warm
Handover scheme so the County Council
started this
um pre-covid wasn't particularly well
supported but what was identified was
there's lots of organizations dealing
with lots of different people
and there wasn't a way of referring
people to a more appropriate
Organization for support
so Suffolk information partnership is a
piece of software that the County
Council owned and organizations join
that to be able to make referrals to
each other
so that is that is what is and that they
call it a warm Handover
the district councils are signed up to
that as as we are there's lots of we're
very strong Advocates of that system and
citizens advice because there isn't
really another system and we're
currently working with the County
Council trying to get them to actually
build a slightly more intuitive system
so that's what the that warm hand over
is
so Council officers we other
organizations fill out an online form
but then they drop down box which
organizations you want to go to then
that organization receives the referral
so that's what that is
okay is that that one all right there
on the next one for us I think was a
voucher scheme
oil so
um
I spoke to Suffolk revenues partnership
last week on a different matter and my
understanding is the southern Revolution
partnership are the organization that do
your council tax will you okay and my
understanding is that they've received
contact from central government
about administering the Alternative
Energy I think that's what they're going
to call it
Alternative Energy scheme which is for
oil users which in the Autumn statement
appears to have gone from 100 pound to
200 pound
um
and I think that SRP will be involved
because they're expecting SRP to make
the payments my understanding is that
individuals will need to they will need
to make application that yougov
and then the details will be passed to
SRP but there's it doesn't appear to be
moving that quickly
and that is an oil
and LPG has now come up for us as well
in in Thurston
in mid-suffolk LPG has come to the fore
as well so
we've got huge concerns about oil and
LPG
and I think the last one for us going to
leave um called the community
supermarkets to die on the team cost a
living coordinator
yeah we're fully involved with it yeah
it's it's a we
we revolved in the conversations before
we got to you for decisions and you know
we see we saw that as one of the first
parts of integration and
um Eliza works very closely with our
team already
yeah okay in terms of the community
supermarkets so we've applied to the UK
shared Prosperity fund to
create develop Community supermarkets
one in baby one with Suffolk and the
purpose of them around the Community
Supermarket is to really kind of that
sustainability about moving people on
from food banks but still not quite
ready to or have financially able to go
back into the supermarkets but they will
always but they will start to pay into
the Community Supermarket so it could be
a normal amount of money and then they
would still be able to go in and
um do their shop
um get some food provided with food in
the same ways they would from a food
bank be the additionality to a Community
Supermarket as well though is that
they'll have there's potentially the the
scope to also provide
um personal shoppers we've talked about
young people also not being able to
leave or leaving the school without
those life skills so it might be that
they'll have a personal shopper that
will support them walking around the
Community Supermarket they will be able
to support them understanding the sort
of nutrition and how to cook healthy
low-cost meals but in addition to that
as well we would like there to be the
kind of common space so that we could
also extend the service to include
social prescribers perhaps have cab
present so that that person has a kind
of holistic support so they're there at
the food or the Community Supermarket
for a reason and so that we'd be able to
provide a wider service almost a bit
like that amount of disciplinary team
that Simon was discussing earlier on
where we are ourselves fully integrated
so it it is a it is similar to a food
bank but they will pay in and there's a
more of a wraparound service that
supports that individual or family
so you're talking about an actual
physical place somewhere in a village
like a village hall or somewhere that
would act as a Community Supermarket
yeah it would be a physical space not
necessarily in a in a village so we
would be only be able to support one in
each of the districts so but we would
work with for example cabs to understand
the best locations for that but we would
commission that piece of work out so
there would be a piece of work around
where the best location would be again
looking at the statistics that enter in
the work that the cabs do in terms of
where perhaps the the greatest need
would be but it would need to be
somewhere relatively Central I'm
guessing so that people could access it
password if you have something on that
response yeah thank you Mr chairman if I
could just on that last part with the
fuel vouchers I actually
I actually represent baber on the shared
Revenue partnership and I do know that
in regards to delivering any fuel
rebates that are they're there from
either government or the councils they
are working extremely hard however I am
actually sitting on a meeting on
Wednesday so I will ask that question
again on that one but also just to add
to that I haven't got the figures for
mid-suffolk but we do actually
issue fuel vouchers ourselves so perhaps
this is where a bit of duplication is
coming in I don't know but just to say
that baber from April to September of
this year they gave out 60 vouchers
total fuel vouchers total in 2 900
pounds so they we are always so oh baby
are also doing their bit on the on the
vouchers as well but I haven't got the
figures for mid-suffic but I think it's
similar to those that baber
you had a question as well
thank you Mr chairman
um
so I guess my question ultimately is
directed at the officers in this
instance
um
and I'm particularly concerned about uh
the cohort of under 25s that are
presenting with difficulties
um and in my day
um which was a bit of a while ago I mean
we had education on home economics and
various other elements of living which
appears to be missing from the education
system but it seems to me also that
there is a vast amount of information
available to the council
maybe as to
who are likely to be in difficulty or
are in difficulty and given that
preventing prevention is better than
cure what can we do as a council to
reach out to these groups
in order to try and preempt the
difficult situation
um and you know that gives us my core
question really and you know you can
obviously work out how that might be
conjunction with the other agencies that
are working in the same field
I think I'll pick that one up if that's
okay
um I think what you've heard throughout
the presentations really from RCA
colleagues is around Community
intelligence and intelligence generally
is really important so understanding and
predicting who those young people are is
not necessarily currently within the
gift or we're not capable of necessarily
doing that exactly I am conscious that
there's been recently a county-wide
carers strategy including young carers
that's been coming forward so I think
there's something we can really look at
there to see where the combination is in
terms of how we can align with that to
pick up those younger people coming
through and I know there is things and
they're around work etc so and and
support so we can have a look at that
directly
um the the idea of us being able to
identify people at risk is the key here
really and that's something that the
refresh plan wants to really look at
moving forward working with our
colleagues in the voluntary sector and
when we talk about that Community
intelligence it's
from yourselves as well as members and
also from all those other organizations
is how do we bring that together where
do we put it and how do we analyze it so
that we can really understand where
those Trends are sitting and then how we
can identify those those individuals at
risk some of their work we're doing
across Council so we're working with our
colleagues in tenant management and
tenant support so they're identifying
some people coming through including
some younger people particularly in
particular housing we're also working
more broadly with our housing colleagues
so they are able to identify people and
we are starting to share all of that
between us now so our internal group
that I talked about at the beginning
includes our housing colleagues our
customer colleagues so where we're
picking that up at the moment is helpful
but I don't think we're yet in a
position to be able to say we understand
that this these 90 young people under 25
are at risk and this is the service that
we're going to provide so that's
something that we're really working on
in the refresh that's going to be a real
priority about how we triangulate all
that information and intelligence it to
enable us to be more responsive and
and obviously as a as a district you
know um young people isn't necessarily
you know um so uh the county runs quite
a lot of work around younger people so
depending on how young we're talking
about
um and we would want to liaise with them
as well and see what they're putting in
place for for example young people
coming out of care what are their
actions because they work with young
people up to 25 and within the post care
system so so it's a work in progress is
what I would say
so Adrian Osborne
uh well thank you very much Mr chairman
um first of all I'd just like to say the
presentation was excellent and uh
Colleen and Simon
um
questions that I were going to ask was
chairman I've been well and truly
answered by uh
by the representatives from the CA and
but there were just one point and I I
don't like to go back on certain items
that we've already asked questions on
but
uh the feeling I have uh particularly
around the Sudbury area is
and I know you've you've talked about
employment but do you find that the
employment side of jobs
particularly as a skilled worker and the
employment that we have got now
is it is is a problem for uh for the
under 25s now
that that was all my question thank you
Mr Taylor
I haven't got any intentions on the
numbers I'm afraid of Adrian but um
we're we're seeing
um young people who are a mixture of him
working out of work so I can't say that
I've seen anything that's
cause concern for
particularly high unemployment figures
at the moment
not something we'd really track your
your box as you say but um but thank you
for that I've just it was just something
that came to mind after a couple of
questions that were already asked which
you you looked at from the employment
exchange people but I have found that
difficult when When I Was Made redundant
years ago so it's no different now I
don't think thank you thank you that's a
Dawson sort of it takes us along
right
um yes just coming up to one with this
gentleman's earlier questions one thing
that bothered me with
um a lot of young people is they're all
on meetings
and I seem to find a lot of people keep
asking how they access the funding
um whether it's via when they come to
system for Icy card get this they can't
get it from baber and they can't get it
from electrical companies are these
people
do they not have the funding because of
the fact they're all meters and of
course these are the very people that
we're really trying to help
um people on prepayment meters are a
huge concern to us
lots of people are put on a prepaid
meter without their own without agreeing
to it
people who are on Smart Meters so maybe
being paid by direct debit and chose to
go on a smart meter
if they go into debit
and into debt with that energy energy
company the Energy company came remotely
revert them to a smart prepayment meter
using the smart meter already in their
houses and they have no say in that that
happens straight away
energy is a huge issue for us
and how we support people going forward
is going to be very very difficult
so on prepayment meters do you have any
left I have a lot of previously we have
a lot of prepayment of vouchers but they
can only be used on non-smart prepayment
meters can only be redeemed at Co-op
East
and you can't use them if you're a
British Gas customer
and sometimes the staff in the co-op
have no idea of what they are or how so
it's making access for our young people
incredibly difficult isn't it it's
incredibly difficult for our advisors to
try and advise people so in mid-suffolk
um over the same period last year we're
228 increase in energy climate issues
and um that's because we're being quite
proactive on it as well so we have an
energy advisor so we're funded
um by
off gem to provide energy advice in
mid-suffet or to specific client groups
but the actual Solutions are becoming
very difficult to they so we will work
with any
body's where somebody is in debt and we
will say to them
you know what can this person do what
payment plan can you enter into what
emergency credit can you agree to put on
the other thing with the vouchers is
that if someone if we can get a voucher
to someone and
Council Osborne says he had the
council's got the same vouchers
that actually goes off to pay the debt
first
so if we give somebody a voucher for 20
pounds and they're 15 pounds in debt
it pays 15 pounds of debt first and
leaves them with five pounds
that's just the way the system works and
if they don't have
um smart needs
to go when they go to a garage does that
mean that we're not helping these
individuals
um who are entitled to this allowance of
400 pounds
but the allowance the ones with the 400
pounds where there has been a delay
for British gas customers in receiving
their credit for 400 pounds if they had
a smart meter because British gas said
they blame the postal strike
so nationally because one of our arms is
is research and campaigns and so what
we've done is we've raised this
nationally and our other offices around
the country have said we've got the same
issue and they tackled British gas and
those are now going out so everybody
will get that 400 pounds
right they will get that 400 pounds
for someone on a prepayment meter
they get the 400 pounds
if you're a direct debit payer it's paid
I think the majority have been paid back
into your account
we're much prefer to see a situation
where everybody's
allowance is paid into their energy but
how do these people get it this is what
I'm trying to how do these young people
who are
um you know you're seeing hardly in
Sudbury that are going down they're
spending 20 pounds every other day or
whatever how are they accessing this
funding then
the only current funding that somebody
that I'm aware of
for both districts is local welfare
assistance
which is an online application
and for a single person it's 100 pounds
and they get 100 pounds in a six-month
period
there is very little support for anybody
anybody with energy costs
prepayments is one side oil and LPG is
as big an issue
in certainly in my district in
mid-suffolk because of the amount of
users and that there is no support
now that's something that the council
wish to look for look to going forward
is some sort of fund
we'd be fully invited
thank you
just going back to the
um
the supermarket thing the uh
I don't have a concern if we are basing
it in one single place in mid-suffic or
my single place in
we are seeing here not just this crisis
we have a loss of bus services
we have we may have vouchers going for
travel but not everyone has access they
may not have a rain car or they may not
have access even if they're going
through a community Transport they have
a limited amount of drivers and there
may be more people wanting to go from
one one Village to get this to access
the food
now when I was a client obviously a b
they had the I'm not sure if you still
do happy advisors that would go out and
travel to see clients I'm not sure
I'm not sure how practical it would be
having in the supermarket thing
traveling to individually but is it not
possible to make it partially remote
having a large vehicle going out to
certain Bridges having certain days we
can visit the village to actually allow
for this Integrated Service of having a
shopper helping somebody go around so
they can travel to that location
otherwise having it in one certain
location and then trying to arrange for
the other option would be having one
location but arranging for a community
bus that visits the location to collects
multiple people to take it in on a
certain day but then again that has a
issue of if a more than one disabled
individual you need to have a bus that
has the capability of taking multiple
disabled individuals so it's lots of
issues about how we're going to get
around it to make sure it's available to
everyone
well in terms of the work we will have
to do up front we'll the work will be
commissioned we will ask the the
provider who will do that to do that
kind of due diligence and that type of
that type of work we will look to see
what's what's worked in other places so
we know that the community supermarkets
have been sort of successful elsewhere
and I also am aware of exactly what
you've just discussed that actually some
people have created those Community
supermarkets to be on Wheels so they're
actually mobile as well so I think what
we'll have to do is just kind of have a
look at best practice what's worked best
elsewhere have a look at our demographic
we know that we are very sort of rural
in our in our makeup and then talk to
those who are involved just to see what
the best options are and it might be
that there's a hybrid approach we don't
know but at the moment that will be part
of the due diligence as and when we
commission that piece of work but we'll
do that up front at the very start
before we Implement anything
you can't stick out um
scarf
thank you
um well question for officers really um
on the five-point plan
page 18 is our response in terms of
coordinating government support and we
talk about in the bottom of the page the
household support Grant where we're
currently distributed just over a
hundred thousand pounds between the two
councils
um it took about the third allocation of
the housing portion of the household
support fund and mention that we'll be
looking primarily to support vulnerable
households in the private rented sector
is often a sector that's actually
forgotten quite often
um and and they're left to their own
means how much uh is available to
distribute within that third round and
the bulk of the first hundred thousand
pounds I think some 75 were spent on uh
debt relief or rent debt relief what are
you going to be spending that money on
in that third round
hello
um so we've got 50 000 pounds per
district for the households
I'm a newbie
can you hear me now
so we've got 50 000 pounds per district
for distribution through the household
support Grant
that's gone to our tenant support
officers who already work within income
maximization benefit applications
um basic budgeting advice not debt not
debt advice
so the idea being that they will catch
people on those wider issues as well it
is a discretionary fund so it's very
much on a case-by-case basis it's not
very strict you're eligible or you're
not it's very much based on who is in
need it does remain open to all tenants
regarding of housing status but we are
trying to
Target those in the private rented
sector more this time around we have a
central Suffolk lettings team within the
council who already work really closely
with the private sector to re-house
homes individuals they have tenant
support officers as part of those teams
and they work very closely so we've
drafted some Communications to kind of
go through those teams to say to those
agents if you have tenants who are
struggling with their rent who are maybe
falling behind to get in touch that's
not to sort of pre-commit and say
they'll all be eligible for assistance
but it's a way of trying to access those
individuals who might be off the radar
in other ways so that we can assess that
um
so that's sort of how we're targeting
private sector tenants but we are not
restricting Council tenants or Housing
Association tenants it is definitely
Case by case it's just making sure that
everybody has equal access to make
applications
um
via telephone or via our website to make
sure it's as accessible as possible
um I hope that answers your question
but councilor well I'm about to take and
then one from councilor Lindsay and I'll
bring questions to an end I think
grilled them enough
thank you chair
um yeah I've still got quite a number of
questions
um you were just talking about the the
50k that's available for each district
and that's for public and private
tenants
so is there something similar for those
who are struggling with their mortgages
or do they go to to ca
um
we also heard that tenant support
officers
can identify people tenants who are
struggling
are the SRP have they got a role in
identifying others who might be
struggling the people who are paying
council tax but not Council rent we need
to I'm thinking that there's quite quite
a lot of ways of identifying tenants who
are struggling but there's not the same
methods for identifying people who are
struggling with mortgages
um
I I'm wondering about is there a
reluctance of some volunteer groups to
join in a coordinated approach and my
knowledge of one or two
voluntary organizations is that they
like to give a service and they like to
see an outcome and I wonder if they
might feel reluctant to join sort of a
multi-disciplinary approach because they
might feel like they're a small fish in
a big bowl and not actually be able to
sort of trump at their outcomes I just
wonder if that's if that's a a drawback
um
and the last question is you know what
can what can we do we've got some
District councils here we've got some
County councilors here
um is there something that we ought to
be doing proactively because you talked
about
um referring to you people that we come
across is there something that we we
ought to be doing in our for many of us
it's religious but for some it's um it's
um Stone Market or Sudbury uh is there
something that we could we could do
thank you
so I can answer the question relating to
those who need support with mortgages
and things like that
um it is a difficult area for mortgages
and those who are struggling
um
sort of wait for more support from the
government hopefully to be announced but
in the interim we can't support those on
a mortgage with the household support
fund but those whose properties are
unaffordable are able we would encourage
them to engage with citizens advice for
money advice and liaise with their
lender however if they are in a negative
budget if they are at risk of falling
behind of losing their homes they can
call us and get support through early
intervention and advice from the
homelessness team I know it sounds a bit
out there but actually unaffordable
properties does put people at risk of
homelessness and they're eligible for
that advice prevention fund while not
intended to be for mortgage arrears and
mortgage payments in exceptional
circumstances could be used for that but
I would advise you know we can't give
Financial advice it's not mortgage
advice but those who are struggling
could contact us that have support
through the Housing Solutions team and
identify other options for them where
possessions proceedings are being
considered by a mortgage lender they are
required to notify the homelessness
department for the local Authority
within which that household sits so we
we should be aware if there are
households struggling
those numbers have been very low we
don't see a huge amount of those
struggling with mortgages contacting us
we would hopefully you know if we've got
somebody struggling they would be
referred into us if
those individuals
my understanding for mortgage support is
that the qualifying period for somebody
on Universal Credit will be dropped from
nine months to three months before they
receive support
but what the Autumn statement did was
we've been nationally saying we wanted
to be supported on the lowest incomes
you know Colleen told you that they they
class a low income household of 17 100
pounds it doesn't seem very much to me
but that's what they classed that at and
most of the support has gone in at that
level so those on means tested benefits
you know will be uplifted and everything
else where we where we foresee a huge
issue coming our way is the middle
ground and I wouldn't even say the
middle ground actually I'd say just
above
the benefit cap area
and into you know the 50 000 plus
household incomes we're going to see
that mortgages is going to be huge for
us
private renters is going to be huge for
us because we suspect a lot of landlords
are going to leave the market and
private rented is already a problem
within our districts the availability
so just to back up what Eliza said there
was what what what would happen is that
you know if we identify somebody that's
come to us for help because they've
walked with your rears or anything else
then we'd be straight away talking to
the housing team because in many cases
if there is equity in the home
the solution is someone to sell their
home
to deal with their debt but then they
cause them a housing issue
so
I'd say that actually in integrated
terms we're quite integrated in that way
already on the for that but it doesn't
take so the other one you said Council
willing was voluntary sectors reluctance
to join
I don't think there's a reluctance to
the join I think that we'll have in the
refresh some forums for other
organizations that we can on a on a
micro basis we spoke about that there's
no point in having a forum in Stow
market with the people in eye or people
in Sudbury for the other area in Milford
it's it's going to be micro forums we'll
get to a better understanding of what
everyone else is seeing
I think that some of the issues if you
if you're perceiving it is that
we are all competitors for funding
in the voluntary sector
so we all want to deliver our own
outcomes
because if we deliver our outcomes we'll
look better to a funder
how we get away from that is integrated
services and everyone agreeing that you
know you are the best place person to do
that you will receive funding for that
but at the moment we're all a little bit
competitors really I think is the the
main issue but I don't foresee going
forward that we will have a problem
bringing in more voluntary sector
organizations
was there anything else the last
question was should we be more should we
be more proactive we counselors be more
proactive yes
councilor Lindsay
well let's uh good I'm sort of picking
that up really because I I just wanted
to give you a couple of examples in my
ward and try and see how
those situations might be dealt with
um
so I I had a resident who is essentially
functionally homeless she's living on a
with her kids and a partner in her
mother's house
and on the sofa bed
and they have a housing department say
that she's not entitled to her she's not
at the top of the list
topic priority for the band A for the uh
for a house
[Music]
uh and they've assessed their income and
so you can have a private accommodation
um and here's for example this plays in
Hadley uh
um private rent
she's telling me
I don't I can't afford it
baber is saying yes you can
I said
all I could say was
have you tried to Citizens advice you
know I don't I don't know but maybe
there's some benefits she could
she's unaware of that she can claim from
the government
make things more affordable and I don't
I don't think she she said oh no no I've
tried it she I don't think she even went
to you but even if she had I wouldn't
necessarily get feedback on on what she
was advised
so
I don't know
I know what the answer maybe that babe
is doing totally the right thing and
that that my my resident just hasn't
understood or I don't know and the other
thing that's cropped up lately
Oklahoma
okay all right fair enough yeah
the other thing was more General
um warm rooms you mentioned about warm
rooms and there's this grant available
um a couple of my parishes have applied
I don't
um
I'm not sure I don't know anything about
the process of what it actually what the
money is for and
we're talking Village Halls which often
aren't particularly well insulated
uh probably the worst the most insulated
building in the village sometimes
um
and
last summer we had temperatures hitting
40 degrees
um
so there's a need for a cold room as
well in summer
um and I don't know whether that that
funding is can cover that the need for
air conditioning or actual material
improvements
two community centers
that allow them to be economic so so you
can retrofit them so they they're
they're warm enough in in Winter and
cold enough
sorry sorry you're going into specifics
again on a particular part of the warm
homes or not not normal homes and warm
places the grant scheme which is a
simple Grant scheme to Parish councils
that they apply for specific things to
be done in a specific place so I think
that's already been I'd like to answer
chair just just very very quickly it's
not specifically just for Parish
councils but it is for smaller for other
community groups as well just to kind of
extend their offering whether that's
just keeping their doors open for an
extra hour or whether there's an
additional Legion that they're putting
on those spaces
um so it's so and the level of Grants
are actually quite small although that
people could apply or groups could apply
for up to five thousand or what's
typically happened is funded a much
larger number of opportunities and
activities so some of the grants are as
small as 200 so it's not thinking long
term and aspect it's just about keeping
those spaces open over the winter months
into spring so that people have a place
to go
I think I'm going to bring the questions
to a close now Council
a quick one then very quickly yes no
answer
or just a very very quick
um it was brought up but we wouldn't
have feedback
um if we refer client to you is a way
that we can integrate especially if we
refer could we be included and have you
got water councilors details if you have
a client who's in a certain Ward would
it be helpful to involve the counselors
in the award so we can have a joint
effort trying to help the the client
case-by-case state it would be casually
case but everything we do is buy consent
so if we had the consent then yes we
would share we obviously there are
occasions where we would really want the
client to give consent so that we give
that feedback because it's ongoing that
that flow bet was affords and that
support that the councilor could provide
you know it's going to be invaluable so
we would always strive to achieve that
right members
we move on that to debate on
well before we go on to move on to
debate then we'll have a quick break as
it's been two hours that we've we've
been we've been sitting here
um so we'll have a quick uh 10 minute
break
right after that short pause Phil
proceed to the debate on
proposals in front of it well not not
the proposals in front of us because we
haven't got any proposals yet as such
but on the
events that we've been asking questions
on
anybody wish to start talking
s chair
ah hello I have an observation that I
think members um
should take on board especially our
character counselors who are in the room
I make no apologies for banging on about
this every platform I have as a teacher
of college age students 16 to 19 what is
happening at present could go on for a
couple of years we are going to have a
backlash of children who are not going
to college on many occasions I have
students come to me and say Miss um I
couldn't come in yesterday
we did not have enough money to put me
on the bus okay some bus fares are like
seven pound return a day if you've got
two or three children at that college
that's 21 pounds a day when I went to
school it was a long while ago uh County
funded bus fares so that was a ticket
for the whole time you were at College
all you did was show your card get on
the bus now there is a reduction ticket
but you have got to find a lot of money
the family to buy that ticket so that
would see you through for a turn
uh I think everybody should be aware of
the Builder of unemployed
young people we might see in the future
because of the state we're in at the
moment and I think
um it would be worth lobbying that all
our County Council colleagues to take
this forward thank you very much
debate then councilors bearing in mind
also the comments that Council
performance just put forward as well
Council scarf
yeah thanks Jay I mean as a County
Council I have a lot of sympathy with
that that view
um I know how it would be met at the
County Council were to be discussed
though uh not in quite such a positive
light unfortunately
um having said that it doesn't stop us
having a go which we frequently do
um
it seems to me from today from the
presentations that we've heard the
overriding factories that we are now
beginning to get closer integration
between the council and its partner
organizations the cas in both mid-suffer
and and in baber and that is really to
be welcomed because I think that is an
area which needed particular
strengthening greatly so I really
welcome that but it also seems to me
that there is an awful lot more that we
can do over the next six months in the
next part of our five-point player
um
I I particularly interested in the
response to
um posts of working our officers working
actually directly at CA or jointly
funded I don't know how it would work
but I really think in terms of
integration that could be a really a
really big game changer in it and
appears from the answers that we got
from CA today that they would be
amenable to that
so I think that's one area that perhaps
we should ask for further uh
investigation work to to be undertaken
in terms of the funding stream from
um Baba and and mid-suffer to their
local Cas I think I've got nothing but
praise for that we have responded uh in
the last year with that huge uplift and
I think that's really good we've now got
the three-year secure funding but
um I think when the review of this 30
uplift takes place uh I think the demand
is going to be even greater than it was
when we actually put that 30 uplifting
in
make some form of recommendation that
you know we support that uplift and
we've seen the work uh that CA has been
able to provide with that uplift even
even though to a degree it's been
actually trying to maintain what they're
what they're already doing rather than
introducing further work
so from the funding point of view I
think we we can do an awful lot more to
support them
um I think the interesting uh thing that
came out of the debate today was we
heard from one of the cas about the
funding from other authorities and the
fact that that really isn't secure and
that
uh as as County councilors too and I
think the County Council perhaps needs
to take a really long serious look
because their residents or our residents
and we can see the benefit for our
residents
from the work of CA why can't they so
I'll leave it at that chair thank you
councilor Barris thank you um
thank you I
I only have really one comment
um on this and that's a little bit of a
concern about the uh Community
Supermarket and how that could be
how that could help many residents I'm
sure it would help some some
significantly but but rolling out that
and making that available to a good
number of people that that would present
significant problems I think because of
location and I can't really imagine
people traveling from a location where
they're near a Tesco's or an Audi to
another location involving some expense
getting there to to be able to buy a
purchase their their goods that they
need
um so I know this is going to Cabinet in
a few weeks time I wouldn't want it to
to be assumed that there was Universal
support for that because I think that
that really does seem a little bit a
little bit tenuous how that can help
many people
thanks
and to agree with you there and
especially representing an extremely
rural
award people are not going to travel a
long ways to it but he's it's an interim
between food bank and the cheaper end of
the supermarkets but the cheaper end of
the supermarket is rapidly being
assimilated into the broad spectrum so
Supermarket base and they're all at the
same sort of level they're all trying to
compete with each other and that is
forcing things to be a little bit more
competitive so it's difficult to see
just how it's going to fit into
accessibility as much as anything else
cancer
thank you very much Mr chairman yes so
I'd just like to share observations from
um
at the moment um
the um these are not I'm not saying that
these aren't things that have been dealt
with but these are things as a counselor
that I'm I've sort of taken away
um this um situation with the men under
25 being at risk um I don't think we can
take that seriously enough
there's there's an increasing Trend in
issues with that age group especially
men
they can be extremely vulnerable and
that Trend can carry on later on in life
when mental health pressures
increase with age Beyond um 25 so um I
think for us as a council that needs to
be something that we take really
seriously right now today and do
whatever we can with that um
data seems to be absolutely key to this
and also um sharing of data this is an
incredibly fast-moving crisis and it's
going to be very hard to react to
um increases in different parts of it
that we that we can't see coming and
that data following that data and being
on it as soon as possible is really
important
um
the um I'm I'm very concerned with
environmental health um not making a
referral due to safeguarding with a
boiler that's not working with potential
mold issues and all the things
associated with that we do have
safeguarding in place within that I
think we we need to look very quickly at
why that hasn't got through to um that
hasn't been taken to the next stage and
um
coordination of food bank sounds like a
really important issue at the moment
um and um
I think local authorities are absolutely
key to doing that um
so um and also yeah a reiterate um if
mid-suffolk oh sorry the local
authorities beaver in mid-suffolk could
get involved in action days and help
support
um the cab with um
that kind of thing I think that would be
a really good proactive way of um
hitting this where it's going not where
it is at the moment or or not where it's
been
um so um yeah for me they're the major
issues that I've taken out there there
are several other issues but um I'll
leave that to the other members to
discuss
first of all I'd like to thank Simon and
his colleague Colleen for their
presentation
um what particularly concerns me and I I
really appreciate the work that you do
with colleagues within the council Miss
Suffolk very very impressed with that
as a former employee of the DWP and its
predecessors for 38 years I find it
extremely disappointing as the statistic
body for administering benefits that
they do not liaise with the cab when I
first joined the Civil Service that's
what we did we we would advise people on
similar type of things that you're doing
dealing with now and I think it would be
it'll be very helpful and you're right
would you say Simon the emphasis is on
getting people into work and I know the
sector state for
um
the DWP is actually been tasked with
looking at that at the Autumn statement
last week but I think it'll be really
good if they could look at this at the
top level and say look there needs to be
more liaison between the local DWP job
center plus particularly and local CA
it's really important thank you chair
make sure that everybody is working to
their utmost efficiency and that means
that they've got to be talking to each
other
at every stage whether it be new boilers
being fitted or advice on benefits or
housing or supermarkets whatever
councilwale
yeah thank you chair I wholeheartedly
agree with that and I think that it's
not just offices I think that that's
something which communities ought to be
doing as well
um I'll put my hand up I know of one or
two things that are going on in my patch
and I've never thought to pass them on
um
and perhaps I should have done or at
least ask the ask the organization to
pass things on when they find people who
are vulnerable
of course there there's there's always
the the difficulty about getting
permission to pass things on because
older people in rural communities are
very private and they don't want anybody
else to know that they they they haven't
they haven't had a meal you know it's
six o'clock in the evening and they
haven't eaten that day they don't want
anybody to know that but we've got to
we've got to be more proactive
um
yeah um and I think uh I think
most of us work quite well when when
people are referred to us as counselors
I remember I'd only been a counselor for
about a week and somebody not it's
knocks at my door and said
the cities is advice in Stone Market
have suggested I come and talk to you
so it does work both ways and
um yeah I mean yeah I was in at the deep
end there where um but managed to help
so yeah we must do that
um I fully support the the uplift
um
and I you know I thank I thank the
officers and and
um uh Susie's advice for all the work
they do and and the presentation what
we've heard from uh both officers and
and citizens advice this morning has
been an eye-opener really to to many of
us it certainly has to me some aspects
of it
um I'm grateful for the uplift I'm sure
um CA we're grateful of the uplift but I
I would like to recommend that this be
continued throughout 23 24 and 24 24 25
because I think that citizens advice
need some certainty we're we're
definitely going into difficult times
for poor Casias
um and there's so much uncertainty
around funding and I think that if we
could recommend
um to whoever we need to recommend it to
that this be can this be continued
for the next two Financial years
just to give them some certainty that
any staff that they are taking on can at
least work for two years because it's
going to be needed so I'll leave it
leave it at that for now chair
proposals for
um recommendations
we should put forward
I would like to suggest to the one that
I just read out a few minutes ago to
facilitate more joined up advice by
actively promoting joint working
I think it's something that encompasses
quite a few aspects of what's been
discussed as one of a counselor Barrett
you had
your hand up well I would like to see
included my my reference earlier about
the caution about the Community
Supermarket I'm grateful to council
Lindsay for raising it because I I've
been uncertain what it what it was
um but I I I would like that that
some caution about that perhaps
um before it
um it becomes part of the a formal
policy
we do have in looking at the report it
does talk about the fact that
understanding the root issues which
Drive Food Bank use is in progress and
it's within that section that food banks
are reported can we put in the
recommendations then that before
anything concerning
uh Community supermarkets is implemented
that it comes back to this committee for
comment
yeah I totally disagree with that I
look they know they know
how to go about this they're not going
to come up with something that isn't
going to work it isn't going to be cost
effective
um so I we don't need to see that we
need to just
encourage them to get on look at look at
best practice across the across the
country and come up with a
a suggestion a solution that's going to
work in mid-suffolk
well as it is a joint meeting I hope you
meant in baber as well
sorry yes I do get a bit parochial at
times
of course the two districts
based on on what I said about more
joined up advice Etc I think one of the
things we ought to consider is the fact
that uh We've we've had a very detailed
and comprehensive report here from
Sudbury and Stone Market
citizens advice
but a lot of our residents utilize
Ipswich and Colchester
citizens advice as well we are bounded
by quite a few areas and people go to
the one that's nearest to them not
necessarily
the ones that we've been speaking about
today so I think by encouraging joined
up more joined up working they can make
we can make sure that we're liaising
quite closely with which I'm sure the
citizens advice do anyway with their
neighboring citizens advice and
organizations
yes please yes it gets a little bit more
focused I think that
thank you chair
um so I've got some recommendations that
for
um committee to consider and the first
one is that the joint of the
institutionary committee notes the
contents of the report and commends the
work being undertaken in response to the
cost of living crisis that the joint
overview and scrutiny committee supports
the 30 uplift to local assistance device
and the work being conducted as a result
and that the council's facilitate a more
collaborative approach between
organizations by encouraging promotion
of joint working there's also I didn't
know if you wanted to include the issue
of the high number of men under 25 class
seriously at least risk be flagged to
the relevant agencies and work carried
out to explore what mitigations can be
put in place to support them further
no I I think um the recommendation that
recognizes the uplift I think needs to
go a bit further include the comments
from counselor William in terms of
extending that uplift through the next
two Financial years that's my first
point uh yeah so my second point is
going back to the comments that I
received from the director of
communities into my question about
proactively reaching out to vulnerable
group I'd like to see a recommendation
that we we understand back from the
director how that's going to be
approached and put into action
if I can just comment on that so I think
that's picked up in the reaching out to
the relevant agencies who are working
with those young people
um in terms of our role in that it will
absolutely depend on what comes through
that so I'm not in a position to be able
to predict that or
or say that we'll be doing a scheme of
work around that because we won't know
we need to get that intelligence in
advance of that so I'm just a bit
it feels like a more Outreach than we
might be able to deliver that's what I'm
thinking
I mean I hear what you say but it seems
to me that a lot of what we're doing is
reactive uh for one reason or another
and I want to me
dealing with the problem we need to be
more on the front foot and that's kind
of where I'm coming from with my
suggestion and I think that's what
councilor Castle was actually also
asking for and I think you know let's
try and nip the problem in the bud you
know before it becomes a bigger problem
which it seems to be the case at the
moment
foreign
get that I understand the proactive
thing and I'm completely with you um I
think
um
we can come back with something I think
it's just being clear about what not not
forcing ourselves into a corner with it
basically being proactive and using that
intelligence we've talked about before
and building the picture before we're
thinking about what the in what we end
up doing and whether it's us that do it
or whether we're encouraging other
agencies who are much better fitted in
order to do that work and we're enabling
or supporting it so it's just getting
that balance really
councilor scarf
yeah thank you I mean um
joint working partnership working Etc I
think we need to be a little bit more
specific about what I think we need to
actually see because
um within the council's staff structure
I think we need to embed a culture where
the cost of living is thought about of
in the same way as when we ask them to
think about the climate emergency
implications
so I think we need to go a little bit
further and actually ask for specific uh
training to staff who are involved in
any area that could have a bearing on
the cost of living to think about the
implications of what they're doing
knowing we've heard about environmental
health today and you know the potential
there was to get some extra help for
that particular resident but I think if
we embed that sort of culture more
within the organization in terms of I
mean we're thinking about it as
counselors we need all staff to think
about it as well so I don't quite know
how to phrase that but I think that that
would be a recommendation I would
support to to Cabinet to sort of cascade
everything down because it's clear the
integration is such an important part
but our staff have a huge role to play
as well
and they might not be thinking about
that first and foremost and indeed as a
common some of them might actually be
suffering from it too you know we assume
that it's it's that lower uh economy uh
the 17 000 pounds that we've talked
about 10
000 many of our staff will be in exactly
the same circumstances and thinking
about it themselves personally but not
might not be thinking about how it
interacts with the residents that they
engage with see what I mean
got any comments on that
I'm right
he took the under 25 groups so just to
read what diets just put for that so
officers to work with relevant agencies
to understand the situation for young
people under 25 specifically young men
and to build a proactive response to
support them as a risk group and then
counselor
you wanted more about the integration so
we've got a council facilitate a more
collaborative approach between
organizations by encouraging promotion
of joint working do you want to add
to that the about the integration that
part
IES
it's a separate item because that is to
that is too generalized in terms of
partnership working it's all so you're
asking officers do you want officers to
examine explore
I think should be embedded as a culture
within the organization
and I think that's the crucial thing
it's up to the cabinet and uh
uh heads of Department to decide how how
that that can occur but I think that
should be uh something that should be
added to our Five Points as it were to
embed that as a culture because if we
don't if we only ever do one thing embed
it as a culture it might lead to other
positive thoughts
see what I mean so it's more specific
yeah
sorry I'm just trying to
um so I'm almost thinking aloud it's
apologies for this but the
the one of the sort of quite shocking
things that I didn't realize that
emerged from this is that there is
nobody to steer people through the
benefit system
if we should somehow recognize that fact
and I but I don't know
quite what we can do about it but
does it mean that de facto the citizens
advice is actually the body that's doing
it in the end
because
the as it were the statutory bodies
don't have to do it so everything gets
referred to Citizen's advice so should
should we sort of recognize that in the
absence of a statutory body
uh to steer people through benefit
system
citizens advice should be regarded as
the
as the body to refer people to or is
that um man I'm interested with someone
from citizens advice here what you think
about that but
is that too much my understanding was
that that that seems to be the de facto
position at the moment
uh that the only people who
deal with the total benefit system if
you like are citizens advice
but Council Caster knew had a comment on
that on that
um we do have to
OLS
um at a dispose of the cost of living
website and the benefits calculator on
um gov dot UK and um as a council we
should really be doing all we can with
social media and whatever channels
available that we have to help people
get onto those before they get to the
point because there's a certain amount
of people that can deal with that on
online and will will be able to use
those tools and we've still got the cab
for the people that can't and need to
speak directly to a person but um
as a as a council I think we should be
pushing those two
tools we have
to
um try and alleviate some of the
workload of the cab
ins you had a
to make members aware
we do have Financial inclusion offices
so when um members of the public pass
through that particular system whether
they be for our own housing stock or for
privately rented stock
they are given benefit advice and and
advice on other things and that takes me
back to where we have to make sure that
we're not duplicating on advice that's
being given and working together with
the cab and ourselves but we are looking
to recruit to that team more financial
inclusion offices so that we can get out
there on the streets and knock on doors
to also give them the that information
as well so that is part of and the
suffix mindset to be getting out there
and doing that as well
that seems to fit in well with our
joined up thinking
aspirations councilor Barrett
thank you um I'm returning to my my
earlier Point
um
um and thank you for your your thoughts
on it but um I think it while it's hard
to be laudable and I agree with the
aspirations to move people through
through the stages
um and give them more support guidance
skills Etc budgeting Etc this
in my papers at all as far as I know
it's not
there's no costs attached to it
um
if this was an initiative coming forward
for Council funding you'd be saying
where's your business plan
um and what what are the what are the
outcomes what are how much the costing
Who's involved how many people is this
going to help where it's going to be
based how people are going to get there
and so on
um
see you nodding so I'll let you come
back
in terms of its funding we have applied
for funding from the UK shared
Prosperity fund there is no council
funding for this as an initiative as it
currently stands and as part of that we
had to provide quite for each initiative
that was going forward into the
investment plan for the shared
initiative uh fund there was an
investment plan and behind all of that
our project plans and business cases for
each of those with with impact the
number of people would be looking for
some of that will be
determined through some of the
commissioning work but actually that
information that you just discussed is
in that in that business case so we do
have all that information we're just
waiting to find out whether or not we've
been successful with regards to the
funding
um
so we've got the first three which I
read out so the joint overview and
scrutiny committee notes the contents of
the report and commends the work being
undertaken in response to the cost of
living crisis that's okay isn't it that
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee supports the 30 uplift to
local citizens advice and the work being
conducted as a result and recommends
that that support continues for a
further two years
yep
that the councils facilitate a more
collaborative approach between
organizations by encouraging promotion
of joint working
and then the
recommendation for officers to work with
relevant agencies to understand the
situation for young people under 25
specifically young men and to build a
proactive response to support them as a
risky group and then the last one
um
that
I love this is that one
is that one
on the side
that cabinet and offices explored how we
can embed the cost of living culture
into the culture of the cost of living
prices in
um into the culture of the organization
for all staff when working with
residents across all departments as part
of a more integrated system of support
does that cover everything uh thank you
chair um
I've learned a lot this morning and
we've spent two and a half hours
listening and discussing and I think
there's a lot of facts that have come
out this morning
um facts from the cities as a vice
offices
um which only about
six people on each of the two councils
are going to be aware of if we're not
careful and I'm I just wonder whether we
can ask Simon on behalf of himself and
his colleague whether a fact sheet could
be put together so that
I don't want it to be complicated just
some straightforward facts so that all
members of both districts are aware of
what the situation is
what what the offices are put together
is great but I've heard so much also
from the citizens advice people that we
ought to be telling other members about
it
I think that uh that's probably
something we can take after we've dealt
with the proposals that the
non-governance officers put forward it's
it there's a proposal and a second
before it
put it out as a note if you like to
the relevant people to produce for us
a joint member briefing on um given by
the ca to update members on the cost of
living I think that would probably be a
better way of doing it than uh
yeah so that was you wanted that as a
recommended I wanted that as a
recommendation
whether it's a briefing or a fact sheet
or whatever it is I think it's important
can I just say my understanding is there
is an all member briefing already
identified for cost of living crisis and
there's a mixture of dates at the moment
I'm not sure when that is I think it's
early in the new year that doesn't
necessarily cut across a written piece
if you were interested in a written
piece but there definitely is an all
member briefing due
and well I would and I'm not sure
whether uh will citizens advice have a
slot at that briefing to talk to all
members because I think I think it's
important that all members here either
on paper or directly from citizens
advice what what the situation really is
on the ground
cancer fighting
as dice said we have it all planned but
I didn't know whether as Simon's so busy
he could just put together like you said
the key facts for us and that could be
attached to our briefing
or would you like to come along or would
like to come along okay
I think that's probably essential that
they've
they're
you'll add that onto the record onto the
recommendations
I do yeah well I'd like to go for the
proposal um we've got some really good
recommendations I'd like to say that um
we this has been a really good meeting
and the um citizens advice um
Bureau and also our officers involved
have showed a huge degree of competence
and um and dealing with a really
complicated um crisis and I believe
we're getting very good value for money
for the money that's going in from the
authorities
um so yeah I'd like to propose the
recommendations as laid out I'd like to
include councilor wellem's
um last one because if we're doing that
already I think that will be having that
tick straight away is fine by me
um and yeah and I'd look for a second
there thank you chairman
second thank you
thank you to conduct electronic vote
except for councilor Osborne of course
thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress
a council I was born
thank you
um I'm also for a
I haven't I'm still trying to get modern
gov opens
it's fine after a reboot
foreign
[Music]
to Jos stroke
22 stroke 24.
overview and scrutiny and cabinet
protocol I'd like to invite corporate
manager for Law and government to
introduce the report to the committee
yep thank you very much thank you chair
um so this protocol has been formulated
and following the council's peer review
and
um it was felt that more definition was
needed around the roles of everyone
scrutiny what the difference between the
roles of overview and squeezing he was
with cabinet and offices and also to
promote a culture of accountability to
openness and transparency within baba
mid-suffolk
um Emily you before she left has done
the majority of the work on this and the
protocol is
um in appendix a and I don't have
anything further to add but if anybody's
got any comments happy to answer any
questions
thank you Mr chairman I have to say this
is a very fine document
um and and it's I think it's a Quantum
Leap Forward from where we were
previously and and our general direction
of travel
um if I have one comment really it would
be to say that as much as possible
um I'd love to see actions that are not
ongoing and have an end date where
possible even if it means that we have
to subdivide that action into a couple
of steps for example
um because I think
one of the key principles that we as
overview and scrutiny have been
concerned about is actually things
getting done and and there's nothing
like a deadline to get something done
thank you
so just to comment on that make
recommendations which have a clear
purpose and set out expectations for
response and implementation
that's already in there
you don't you
10 we're talking about the protocol not
the action we're talking about the
protocol not the action plan
so it's covered in it's covered in the
protocol let's put it that way in the
protocol sheet in the lovely pink sheets
councilor Grandin
thank you chair
um I'm particularly pleased to see the
um section referring to the cabinet
cabinet members will
um because sometimes I wonder whether
the work that we do here kind of ends up
in a black hole and you know we did some
I hope that what I think very valuable
work
and I worry that sometimes it ends here
um so I'm quite pleased to see
that section there where it's formulated
that cabinet members will
take notice of what we are saying but
um can I ask
um our corporate manager
is there another part
where cabinet members
hear this and say cabinet members will
so that they you know is there something
that formulates the fact that they have
to listen effectively
yes chair um for you
um this paper will also be taken to
cabinet for them to agree as well so
we're going down the process and
obviously officers will
um it'll be taken to well it has already
gone to senior leadership team and they
have endorsed it so it will go formally
to cabinet for them to approve we're
also holding regular
um cabinet and chairs of scrutiny and
vice chairs scrutiny meetings with with
them on a regular basis now to discuss
anything coming up so we are much more
although we still need to maintain this
um you know the need to be separate to
maintain your Independence we are
working much more closely with them
so can I just um
uh kick a little bit further please
um so will that include
um
a sort of formal bit where cabinet
members
are expected to review
our decisions or our work
where they do that sort of specifically
um they they're the the formal review is
when you send your recommendations to
Cabinet that's when they review and also
um you have to take your work uh annual
work program to to
um Council so all counselors can review
it and the chairs regularly update to
Council on the work of overview and
scrutiny so that it is a constant review
but the formal recommendations are
obviously taken to a formal meeting for
approval
thank you Mr chairman
um yes absolutely I agree with this
area that um
Emily you'll provided before she left
I do like
I do like this and I do like to see on
the scrutiny cabinet protocol how will
we achieve it I think those those bullet
points down there say it all
particularly the first one
and well all three of them are all six
of them actually and yeah that's
excellent excellent lead piece of work
done by by the governance thank you
Council Barrett
thank you chair
um I'd just like to see a little
addition to this
um to say uh under the the overview and
scrutiny committee members will
um second Point
um participating in regular training to
develop their skills include including
calling
um and to be very very clear
um to Define that to um to advise when
when it's appropriate and
um how how to present and how how it
will run because that I think I I was
involved in one and it wasn't very
immediately clear to me I might have
covered it in a previous training but I
think it perhaps it could be it could be
more
more explicit
we can certainly add that but just to to
add reassurance I'm now working on the
induction program for new councilors and
call in is a major part of the training
for new councilors coming in next year
there's going to be a whole section on
calling
thank you chair I mean I I really do
welcome this because I feel that at
times there's been a bit of a disconnect
between scrutiny and cabinet and
probably on both
and come back to the point that scrutiny
has a tremendous value to the council if
it works well it works for the cabinet
it works for the council and it works
for us
but I think the one thing I would like
to highlight uh is under the overview
and school year committee members will
and I think sometimes this is
misconstrued but provide constructive
challenges a critical friend of the
cabinets
decision and policy making and I think
there's a growing recognition of the
role that scrutiny does actually play by
cabinet and I do really welcome that
because we we
uh and sometimes being critical but I
hope that we always come across with
constructive recommendations to Cabinet
whether or not they are actually
adhered to or not is a matter of a
cabinet and completely rightly so uh and
equally uh I think it's really important
that scrutiny uh has a role to play in
investigating anything that has a
bearing on our residence regardless of
cabinet are looking at because we are an
independent committee and I think that
role is really crucial that we we
recognize that and I'm sure we do as
scrutiny committee members but
to take recognition of that as well
I think that was a combined almost
debate and questions session
can I have a proposal for
councilor Osborne
second there councilor Grandin
the officer will now conduct the
electronic vote
chair members that vote is now in
progress councilor Osborne
before
councilor Barrett do you want me to take
a vote verbally
oh thank you so China makes 12 votes for
stats unanimous
thank you members
move on to item nine Jos stroke 22
stroke 25 forthcoming
oh a big department forthcoming
decisions list yes that's the tracker
that's not calm down
we get a bit out of sync I think on the
pages
the office is trying to
hit me on my toes by just providing a
link to
terms
any comments on the
forthcoming decisions list
thank you chair only to say that it's
for noting
um and those of us who have read it have
read it
um and uh
I didn't in my reading of it was that
there's nothing there that needs to be
brought forward into our work plan so
I'm happy that we just note it thank you
did
and into the country
no thank you
item 10. Jos 2226 overview of scrutiny
action tracker
this is the one I think
cancer happened well my previous uh
comment stands uh chairman
uh yes chair we've made real progress of
this I think the officers who have done
the work on this I think this proves to
me that the tracker is only as good as
the recommendations that we make and if
we don't if we don't if we're not smart
in our recommendations the tracker can't
be smart either so I think this has
highlighted that we need to be smarter
and and we will attempt to be smarter in
the future look
thank you chair
oh and second that in terms of the
the progress we've made on this action
tracker because it has certainly
improved things considerably
there was just one suggestion I made um
I'd like to make and that is on page 35
um uh towards the bottom
1.3 or 1.4
and that is about
uh a training session
and I would suggest that rather that we
try to fit that in before March that
that that be part of the training that's
given to new members of overview and
scrutiny thank you chair
we can note that note that that
suggestion
there was also a suggestion made a
little bit earlier about uh
clarifying the
the wording of page 33 1.2
on parking which was cabinet is
requested to carry out further work to
replace car parking demands to clarify
that that was to reduce
car traffic as much as anything else and
by providing Alternative forms of
transport
do you want me to comment yeah I
I felt that that was not as clear as it
could be
using the word replace so
I'll take take your advice on whether
that can be noted or taken forward
that's a recommendation that that's been
formally approved by by this committee
so we can't actually change the wording
but I think we can put a note in there
somewhere to uh to clarify it
thank you chair um yeah just to clarify
that I will make a note of that as your
chair says we can't actually change your
recommendations but in the future action
trackers
I'll put a little note in to explain
exactly what that recommendation means
just for clarity
it just took on the
Council awareness suggestion about
training course I mean that's actually
uh we should more than notice or if we
agree that that's a new instruction for
officers isn't it
if it's um
knowledgeable
I suppose the time isn't stated in the
indirect thank you chair
um councilor Lindsay in regards to that
point of appointment that uh councilor
Wellen raised I will be um talking to
Vicki the key officer about that and
I'll be raising councilor willem's
suggestion
um once I get feedback from her and a
decision that'll be then included in the
progress section of the action tracker
you guys would all be made aware
buttons the action tracker is for noting
are you all happy that we note that
the action tracker
nodding dogs are all going yes yeah good
thank you that's noted
now we're going to the baber overview
and scrutiny work plan
this is for baby members have you any
comments on the work plan
foreign
[Applause]
listed Beyond January at the moment
for the the remainder of this Council
is that correct
we need something in there I would like
to propose
um public realm and Street cleansing
we've now had
um this in-house for a year since uh the
ending of the idvodi contract and I'd
like to examine that and see whether the
impact has been whether they're up to
whether they feel they're um they've
caught up with the work that was
outstanding and how they're rolling out
their their service now that it's
in-house
unless he wanted to add that to the
mid-suffic one as well
sure
um however my other point was it seems
to me that we have a huge agenda for
January yeah and then we haven't got
anything timetable past that and and I
just wondered whether actually we needed
to consider all of those items in
general whether some could be put into
the February meeting
thank you chair uh so this is something
that I have picked up I am very
conscious of the work plan for January
is quite loaded
um we decide we work plans at the Joint
chairs briefings and we have one next
week uh what we will probably look to do
is move one or two of them items onto
the February work plan at the moment
it's looking like that will be the
update on the electronic complaint
system and the baber only item that is
for scrutiny of cabinets communication
and sharing of information that looks
like it might be moving to February but
obviously we will have to
um formally approve that at the Joint
shares briefing next week
thank you
I can come back on that the the in
January we we're looking again at the
general fund and housing Revenue
accounts which is a huge item and I I
personally believe that should be the
only item on that particular meeting
everything else should get moved forward
the chairman of uh
mid-suffix over in scrutiny who's
nodding away when you suggested that
um I think at the Chairman's briefing
next week then it's likely that
everything else is going to get moved
forward
yeah I'm not quite sure exactly what we
will be doing with the general fund of
the HRA when it comes back because
um we're looking at the the um general
fund and the HRA tomorrow the mid-suffer
and you'll be looking at it this
afternoon
um
I'm not sure how much will be left to do
uh when we review it again in January so
I'm not
I'm not I'm not sure what value we can
add at that point
I'm not saying there isn't any but I'm
just trying to get in my in my head
exactly what we will do it says it's
review savings proposals and updated
position
um what we mustn't do is to go through
the whole
the whole thing again
without being too too cynical with uh
London politics at the moment and
there's a fair chance that there might
be another budget before then which
might change the whole thing I mean it
does say that what we're looking at what
we're going to look at what you're going
to look at tomorrow and we're going to
look at this afternoon
there are no the savings is the
controversial being
The Cutting what service is going to be
cut and there's nothing in there about
what's going to be cut
so I think what we're bringing forward
in what is it in your follow in January
is actually well this is where we're
suggesting we're going to cut
and that's quite crucial isn't it
Melissa you had something to at least
about from the beta figure I haven't
looked at them yet it's obvious there's
a big hole
oh
let's keep it specific we're on the
paper action plan here
so in terms of everything that's being
discussed
the budgets coming back in January is
something that Melissa Evans has
requested she is going to be invited to
the Joint chairs briefing next week
where we will formally have a chat with
her about what that item is actually
going to entail
um there we would then be able to make a
decision on it's coming to a scrutiny
Committee in terms of what everyone's
suggestions have been about moving items
on the work plan we do in January have
some quite time sensitive items so the
review of the culture Heritage and
visitor economy strategy does have to go
to the January committee so there are
some
unmovable items but as I said earlier
we'll have those discussions next week
about what work plan for January and
February March is going to look like so
I would assume that that will be thinned
down but we will have to have
discussions with all of the officers
about what is actually going to come to
that committee
so Baba members
are you content to note
the action plan
I'll take the work plan really I mean in
the same way that mid-suffic I think if
we can get some of the stuff from
January moved
later to later meetings when the agenda
is bare then um no it makes sense I
think that's well where where it's
possible to redistribute the workload
then that obviously makes a lot of sense
because sitting in here for too long can
be uh
had to production
suggestion which are probably a lot of
film Council about the term yeah I've
made a note of that for next week's
discussions
yes counselor when I'm bearing in mind
this is the baby action yeah yes and
that's that's why I put my hand up
because
the the review of savings proposals in
updated Position will be quite different
from the the baber perspective of the
mid-suffle perspective so that probably
can't be a joint meeting well that's
something we can discuss that week as
well so
yeah so we're in the situation over
today and tomorrow where we've got three
we've got three meetings
um we we would be best to to avoid
having three meetings on the 23rd 24th
of January
so with that I'm getting some notes so I
think
if members agree that's what we should
aim towards then they would have got a
baber only
um uh item in January as well
but
it's difficult to discuss the baby the
baby work plan without thinking about
the midsummit work plan because
from a mid-suffer point of view
it there might not be enough for a whole
meeting in that item on the general fund
I think cancer Acme is probably going to
disagree with me but
um
but that's a position that we're moving
ourselves towards
trying to avoid a load of meetings like
what we have this week what we can do
that we can decide next week for January
is to hold a simultaneous meeting
I think that would work so we have
both councils would review the general
fund and the budget separately so what I
could suggest is that baber would go
first and then we would do a joint
session with both committees on the
cultural heritage and visitor economy
strategy and then at that point the baby
members would leave whenever mid-suffic
members would stay and discuss their
budget so we do one day that works
yeah I think that's a good idea and
that's what I proposed for today and
tomorrow that it just wasn't going to
work
um
but yes if we can do that then that
would be that would be ideal
finalize that next week
strategy meeting as well yeah
but we don't we don't want to go second
and still be here at six o'clock in the
evening
I'm quite happy for us to be here at six
o'clock this evening starting the next
one yeah
it's got dates for 20th of March 20th of
April
um
and then it says pre-election period but
I was saying that 20th of March and 20th
of April are in the pre-election period
of the 20th of April must be sure yeah
oh I see okay I'm with it sorry just
just to clarify the pre-election period
for the
disc start on March the 16th
16. okay thanks March for parishes
so that we can hold our council meeting
at the end of March
I don't know the date exactly but it's
about 20th isn't it yeah sorry I'll look
the straying off the way from the action
plan again
baby members happy to note the action
plan
yes right thank you
mid-sufficient Japan do you want to take
that one councilor Wellen more which
can can I propose that we note it and
all all Lord and go home
[Applause]
nice nice to know the work ethic is
still there yes
[Laughter]
that that concludes the business of this
meeting but before you all disappear
this year's got a bunch of his wishes to
make
yeah so this is in terms of the labor
overview in scrutiny committee that is
happening straight after this obviously
on my papers it's scheduled for one
o'clock but I think everyone needs a
lunch break so we will still have what I
propose is that the pre-meeting starts
at 1 30 with the committee starting at
two so that's the baby members only if
that is okay
you want to start earlier that's fine
baby
baby members how long do you do you need
a pre-meeting or do you want